[Music]
2022 began with strikes in French
overseas territories public sector
employees in Guadalupe protested against
high prices and the rising cost of
living
it exposed the underlying ethnic and
racial tensions but many say they're
still treated like a colony
and covid-19 restrictions were lifted
people took to the streets to voice
their demands for higher salaries and
better working conditions
the protests caused travel disruptions
hundreds of flights were canceled when
airport workers walked off the job
calling for better contracts and the
rehiring of employees who were let go
during the pandemic
our movement is based in a need for more
stuff and the fact our bonuses haven't
been reviewed since before the pandemic
in the energy sector industrial action
resulted in Long queues at fuel stations
disgruntled staff say multinational
corporations make large profits but the
disparity in salaries remains
we can understand that people are angry
when they have to queue but it is not
our intention to make them wait for us
the only option is to go on strike we
stop the Productions so there are
inevitably repercussions and they don't
negotiate so the only thing that works
is force
when Energy prices skyrocketed in Europe
France spent billions to cushion the
effects of inflation to prevent
household bills from more than doubling
next year Energy caps will cost an
estimated 16 billion dollars
foreign
people say the government must do more
even with the cap energy costs have
increased by 15 percent which is twice
as much as the minimum wage even doctors
and paramedics joined the picket line
we want people to know that we can't
take it anymore that we need better
working conditions in order to better
take care of them because what we want
is care time with patients
[Applause]
in the peak holiday season at the end of
the year Railway workers went on strike
although last minute negotiations
prevented major cancellations unions say
issues haven't been resolved it stands
and defends the interest of the
corporations of the big banks of the
companies in general and the
shareholders the the government is of
course
very intent on trying to contain these
strikes and certainly not giving in to
them in order for it to avoid the
situation where the strike will spread
and workers would Inspire each other to
go on to a general strike especially
considering the fact that they are
intent on presenting uh pension reform
in January which will lead to heightened
social tensions president Emmanuel
macron wants to overhaul the pension
system already postponed in 2022 he's
likely to go ahead with the plans in
January
what I propose in this reform is
Shifting the legal age progressively to
65 years we are abolishing the special
pension plans because this is a real
Injustice and there are real
discrepancies so we are shutting them
down but labor unions are opposed to the
proposal which would save the government
billions of dollars France's year of
strikes may be over but the government
is poised to make changes for retiring
workers the unions in the past have been
able to postpone the proposed reform
forms but 2023 is likely to be a year on
track for more strikes and More Union
action unless wages are increased and
there are more jobs